you've seen her in wargames The
Breakfast Club twice in a lifetime and
st. Elmo's fire you've seen him in
police academy 1 & 2 diner in cocoon
but right now you got to see them
without paying admission co-starring
tonight to give out the Oscar for
achievement in documentary short
subjects our Ally Sheedy and Steve
Guttenberg
a lot of people don't just watch the
Oscar show they make a game out of
trying to guess the winners documentary
short subjects is one of the toughest
Oscar pool categories there is because
for the most part people haven't heard
of or seen these movies aside from being
a part of the Oscar pools we hope the
attention giving these films tonight
will encourage more people to seek them
out films that deserve Oscars certainly
deserve audiences the nominees for
achievement in documentary short
subjects are the courage to care Robert
Gardner producer Pete's and is
nightingale a blind date Michael Crowley
and James Wolcott producers making
overtures the story of a community
Orchestra barber will a sweet producer
witnessed war dr. Charlie Clements David
Goodman producer The Wizard of the
strings Alan Edelstein producer
witnessed or dr. Charlie
thank you very much this is a great
honor for us I want to thank the many
people who helped make this film
possible and in particular skylight
Pictures the American Friends Service
Committee and especially Joe Volk most
of all I want to thank Charlie Clements
whose acts of conscience and courage and
his willingness to speak out have been
an inspiration to us all I also want to
introduce Deborah Schaeffer who is my
partner on the film and the director we
would like to dedicate this award to the
memory of Archbishop Oscar Romero who
was murdered six years ago today in El
Salvador and to all of those who are
keeping his spirit and his dreams alive
by working to prevent another Vietnam
war in Central America thank you